[Musique]
bonsoir notre rendez vous du lundi soir
en direct audition publique avec lcp
assemblée nationale public sénat et le
figaro live merci d'être fidèle toutes
les semaines nous sommes en direct donc
pour une heure de débats de
confrontation pour faire le point aussi
sur tous les enjeux du moment alors
évidemment les retraites les municipales
l'agriculture bien sûr puisque notre
invité ce soir est le ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
au cours de cette émission vous allez
voir se succéder sur ce plateau mes
consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
puis deux parlementaires qui viendront
débattre avec vous un sénateur et un
député
et puis yves thréard du figaro qui
viendra conclure toute cette session
d'une heure sans oublier évidemment les
questions qui interviendront au cours de
l'émission via le figaro live et que je
relaierai ici en direct une première
question les inondations dans le sud est
de la france qui ont déjà fait six morts
l'impact sur l'agriculture est important
je vais vous répondre mais permettez moi
quand même en ce jour de deuil national
d'avoir une pensée pour les treize
soldats que pour lesquels nous avons une
cérémonie très émouvante
cet après midi aux invalides présidé par
le président de la république
le sang versé de ses militaires là pour
la france est quelque chose de fort et
je pense que nous devions avoir une
une pensée pour pour eux en démarrant 7
cette émission est favorable pour les
pour les six de nos concitoyens qui en
péril et trois sauveteurs et puis la
personne qui est hébergé cette l'île
verte chez vous en essayant de sauver
ses chevaux et la dame qui a péri au
volant de sa voiture ce sont des drames
et c'est la nation c'est la communauté
nationale qui est en deuil à travers les
soldats au mali ceux qui luttent pour
notre liberté à travers ceux qui
essayent de sauver lorsqu'il a des
intempéries et puis voilà les personnes
qui sont quelles sont les répercussions
sur l'agriculture de ses innovations
dans le sud est
elles seront elles seront évidemment
forte c'est très difficile de répondre
aujourd'hui très précisément il ne peut
pas y avoir d
d'évaluation précise il faut attendre
que l'eau baisse vous savez nous sommes
dans un moment où les aléas climatiques
sont de plus en plus fort la neige ou la
grêle la bétonisation des terres
agricoles est aussi mise en cause est ce
que vous vous retenez cette explication
on en parle depuis longtemps il est
possible que l'artificialisation des
terres que le fait que l'on construise
plus de routes plus de lotissement plus
de goudron solution est trop loin plus y
contribuer il est certain que nous
sommes allés beaucoup trop loin ces
vingt dernières années
aujourd'hui je pense que les maires en
cette responsabilité de freiner cette
urbanisation à à tout rompre et les
maires aujourd'hui jouent un rôle
essentiel pour lutter contre
l'artificialisation évidemment
évidemment ces lotissements qui sont
partis à perte de vue qui sont rentrés
dans les champs après ça pose d'autres
problèmes de cohabitation
aujourd'hui c'est fini tout cela oui ce
serait un enjeu pour les municipales
certainement on va accueillir maintenant
thème traduit de public sénat et
brigitte boucher de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
[Musique]
bonjour brigitte coeur et ses tables qui
commence ce soir pour parler des
retraites
évidemment et oui car vous étiez comme
l'ensemble du gouvernement séminaire
gouvernemental hier après-midi sur les
retraites
est-ce que vous avez été rebooster pour
affronter l'as les grandes
manifestations du 5 décembre
nos normes il s'agit t il ne s'agissait
il ne s'agissait pas pardon d'être
boostée pour affronter les
manifestations il s'agissait de partager
ensemble la situation ce qui allait se
passer à partir du 5 le 5
et puis surtout comment se dire qu'il
fallait avancer mais premier ministre
nous nous à nous a dit de partager ce
moment sur la réforme universel vous
savez présente la république à emmanuel
macron candidat à la présidentielle
avait dit je réformé le régime de
retraite pour en faire un régime de
retraite universel qui soit équitable
aujourd'hui notre régime de retraite il
est trop complexe il est injuste et les
fragiles économiquement et donc il faut
que ce régime universel fasse que chaque
point donne la même chose pour tout le
monde c'est ce que nous allons faire
c'est pas du tout un régime
on entend beaucoup de choses et l'heure
une manifestation qui risque d'être très
suivie en fait dans cette réforme des
retraites il n'y a aucune stigmatisation
il n'y a pas du tout la volonté de faire
une transition brutale qui serait une
erreur
il n'y a pas non plus la volonté de
faire de ce qu'on appelle la clause du
grand-père qui reporterait sa à 40 ou à
40 ou 50 sondage ifop qui est parue dans
le jdd dimanche
76% des français approuvent la réforme
la réforme des retraites que vous avez
proposé en revanche 64% des français ne
vous font pas confiance pour mener cette
réforme est ce que vous avez déjà perdu
la bataille de l'opinion n'est pas du
tout parce que moi ce qui m'importe
c'est le premier chiffre c'est que 76%
des français pensent qu'il faut réformer
ce régime de retraite mais pas cette
carte formule mais attendez non mais ça
brille mais pas avec vous de ça veut
dire qu'il faut attendre encore
longtemps peut être encore sept ou huit
ans donc il au mieux la faire maintenant
ça il n'y aura plus de retraite que nous
disent les jeunes
aujourd'hui on sait même pas si on aura
une retraite un jour personne ne croit
plus est cette retraite est les troupes
et les tropiques équitable et donc ce
que nous voulons faire vraiment vous dit
pas c'est pas cette réforme là je suis
désolé de vous dire pas cette réforme là
elle n'a pas été présenté cette réforme
là comme vous le dites
la négociation est encore en cours
le haut commissaire jean paul delevoye
va discuter encore avec les syndicats
jusqu'au 7 ou 8 mai santé discutait
quand même janvier ça s'appelle une
concertation sa bougie mouchée et le
premier ministre vers le 9 10 11 12
décembre
peu importe la semaine d'après va
annoncer les arbitrages quelles sont ces
arbitres action très simple trouvez vous
normal vous mesdames qu'une femme
aujourd'hui il est un écart de 42% de
pension de retraite par rapport à un
homme
trouvez vous normal que lorsqu'une femme
a une carrière hachée parce qu'elle a
souhaité garder ses enfants parce
qu'elle n'a pas eu la possible de
travailler soit sanctionné mais là on
est d'accord d'inquiétude pour les
femmes c'est exactement ce que nous
avons vu qu'il avait savoir c'est pas ça
parce que la valeur du point et qui va
gérer le point qu'on voit peut-être pas
mais on voit peut-être pas les mêmes
français mais moi les français ce que je
vois me disent ah bah si demain lorsque
j'aurai des retraites h et vous savez
aujourd'hui on peut faire deux trois
métiers
si on fait deux trois métiers de trois
entreprises là trois caisses de retraite
you into my n'aura plus que déjà annoncé
que vous voyez souvent ce sont les
agriculteurs évidemment talent
justement les agriculteurs qui ont des
retraites très modeste c'est ce qu'il
faut attendre cette réforme pour
revaloriser la retraite des agriculteurs
est ce qu'il faut pas tout de suite
avancé sur ce dossier est immédiatement
valoriser revaloriser leurs amis et bien
sûr le beurre l'argent du beurre la
crémière le sourire c'est pas le sujet
nous sommes là aussi pour les comptes
publics
je veux emmener sur la réforme des
retraites attendez attendez attendez
attendez ne mélangeons pas tout s'il
vous plaît parce que c'est déjà
tellement complexe vous dites que les
français ne nous font pas confiance
parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas notre
effort nous n'avons pas encore présenté
nous voulons de l'équité de la justice
en taboulé story alors je réponds pour
les agriculteurs la réforme des
retraites sera très favorable aux
adducteurs pourquoi tu reprends les
camions parce qu'ils sont y a pas de
grand gagnant c'est pas une retraite ou
les gagnants et des perdants
c'est une retraite de justice et de
justice sociale pourquoi les
agriculteurs globalement vont y gagner
mais part de tellement bas vous lisez
dans votre question que forcément ils
vont ils vont gagner chaque année il ya
environ trente mille agriculteurs qui
prennent leur retraite
sur les 30 millions environ 10000 qui
sont en dessus d'eux
des 1000 euros des 85 100 du smic donc
cela ne seront pas impactés et les vingt
mille autres seront gagnants donc pour
les agriculteurs il ya vraiment zéro
perdant tout le monde va dans l'ads est
dans la main de dire ce que une fois
cette réforme adoptée tous les
agriculteurs gagneront minimum 1000
euros par mois absolument
c'est là qu'est le guardian à qui le
guen déjà et tout le monde est le
gagnant alors une fois la réforme
adoptée mais vous dites y en a vingt
mille qui est aujourd'hui gagnent moins
de 2000 euros des 85% du smic est ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer que ce soit
rétroactive pour cela alors là dans la
réforme je ne connais absolument pas
rétroactif pour aucune catégorie de
français aujourd'hui ce que je veux
vraiment dire là devant vos
téléspectateurs vos auditeurs et ce qui
pourrait être écrit dans le figaro c'est
que tous les retraités d'aujourd'hui qui
touchent une retraite ne sont pas
concernées par cette réforme
leurs pensions ne seront pas impactés
nil ne perdrons nil de gagnon ni de
rétroactivité non c'est bien dans très
clair et net pour ceux qui sont
retraités permettez moi de prolonger un
tout petit instant ceux qui sont pas
encore retraité mais qu'ils n'entreront
pas dans le cadre de la réforme c'est à
dire ceux qui sont nés à partir de la
date aujourd'hui de 63 qui pourrait être
bouger s'il ya une transition qui est un
peu plus large ne seront pas concernés
non plus ne seront pas impactés
c'est important de le dire parce que
tout le monde s'inquiète sur des sujets
qui ne valent pas la peine de
s'inquiéter
un autre sujet d'inquiétude ce sont les
conjointes d'agriculteurs qui ont
souvent tout autant travaillé dans
l'exploitation tout au long de leur vie
médian qu'en moins de pension de
retraite est ce qu'il faut leur créer un
statut et pour qu'elle ait davantage de
droits alors nous sommes en train d'y
travailler la semaine dernière avec jean
paul delevoye nous étions avec tous les
responsables des syndicats agricoles
spécialiste de la fiscalité et du social
pour en parler nous savons que c'est un
vrai sujet notre beaucoup avec la msa
la discussion n'est pas terminée je
pensais faire partie de la réforme des
retraites avant la réforme des retraites
c'est qu' il y ait pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qu'il soit agriculteur
ou pas mais ce qui m'importe plus que
d'autres sans corse et les agriculteurs
sur c'est la responsabilité que j'ai
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que il
demain ce soient plus équitables pour
eux quand on travaille quasiment 7 jours
sur 7 toute sa vie que l'on touche 500
ou 600 euros de retraite par an
c'est absolument pas normal avec la
réforme des retraites la laddh le régime
universel
ce ne sera plus le cas ce sera mille
euros
revoir là que le statut des conjoints et
fait partie de la discussion de la
réforme des retraites brigitte la
pénibilité qui devrait être prise en
compte dans ce nouveau système de
retraite est ce qu'elle concerne les
agriculteurs et si oui comment à quel
niveau
alors l'appareil cette émission se passe
à un moment où les discussions ne sont
pas terminées les arbitrages ne sont pas
fait ce que moi je suis reparti
plausible mais bien sûr que la culture
est un métier pénible mais évidemment
évidemment qu'entraver 7 jours sur 7
quand on va quand on va traire ses
animaux ou quand on travaille dans les
champs bien sûr que c'est un métier où
on pourrait mais s'est crashé le métier
pénible
nous voulons regarder l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs pour faire en sorte que
cette réforme soit favorable à celles et
ceux qui ont un usage éviter pour aînés
mépriser la pénibilité peut être tous
vos tenues dans la réforme des retraites
pour les agriculteurs elle peut l'être
une question politique plus large
selon la réforme des retraites passe ou
pas est-ce que c'est l'avenir du
quinquennat qui se jouait ce que vous
jouez gros avec cette réforme une
réforme essentielle
non mais c'est l'avenir de notre société
qui est en jeu là je pense que les deux
grands mots enfin si cette réforme ne
passe pas surrégime n'étant pas
équilibré aujourd'hui on dit que c'est
entre 10 12 milliards d'euros par an
comment on fait pour comment
faisons-nous pour pour avancer donc
c'est pas l'avenir du quinquennat qui se
joue c'est l'avenir de nos enfants de
nos petits enfants c'est beaucoup plus
nous apportant milk dont il faut faire
les deux réformes en même temps il faut
que ce régime soit équilibrée et
fonctionne régime soit en gros gagnant
gagnant alors on va parler maintenant
des dossiers agricoles parce que demain
il ya un rendez vous entre la fnsea et
le pourrai me disent prêts gîte et vous
aussi à didier guillaume vous rencontrez
donc là effet nationale y aura deux
thèmes à l'ordre du jour si j'ai bien
compris agri bashing revenus des
agriculteurs
est-ce que vous avez des annonces qui
sont prévues à la sortie non mais nous
dit moi je discute tous les jours j'ai
dit avec les agriculteurs il ya deux
sujets le premier sujet il est
aujourd'hui très important au moins
aussi important que tous les autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle la ghriba chine
le dénigrement permanent
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas continuer à
accepter par un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens pas par tous une infime
minorité mais sans cesse de
de critiquer les agriculteurs dire ce
sont des pollueurs dire ce sont des
empoisonneurs ce n'est pas vrai quand on
sait que notre agriculture est une des
plus durables du monde et quand on sait
que l'alimentation qui est issu de cette
agriculture elle est saine elle est sûre
elle est durable est tracé et donc moi
je veux sans cesse être le bouclier
j'aime l'agriculture non non non mais
c'est très attendu oui mais non mais
c'est très important parce que à force
de contribuer à cela on contribue à
faire en sorte que demain il n'y ait
plus d'alimentation et de la culture
française et les citoyens décideront les
hauteurs de la ghriba shing c'est qui
mais ce sont des citoyens ce sont des
associations ce sont certaines certaines
ong qui passent leur temps à cibler a
ciblé a ciblé la culture française se
sont joués de l'histoire est le deuxième
sujet non l214 ont fait partie des
lanceurs d'alert donc les uns sur
d'alert c'est bien notre démocratie
mais moi ce que je condamne forme
fermement c'est quand on rentre d'un
jeune qui travaille comme ça s'est passé
dans l'hérault femme avoue qu'à
reprendre hulk l'entente brûlent des
bottes ça c'est inacceptable
le deuxième sujet effectivement c'est le
revenu des agriculteurs y avait de très
grandes attentes envers le gouvernement
après les états généraux de
l'alimentation la loi agriculture et
alimentation qui avait promis aux
agriculteurs d'être justement rémunérés
est-ce que vous reconnaissez l'échec du
gouvernement sur ce point qu'est ce que
vous allez changer
non je reconnais pas du tout l'échec du
gouvernement parce que ce que vous dites
je connaîtrai les joueurs dans la rue
ils sont encore dans la rue sont restés
un jour dans la rue le thème principal
c'était halte à la ghriba chine et
donnez nous du revenu nous y travaillons
dans la loi et galip j'ai rencontré tous
les syndicats agricoles ces dernières
semaines et particulièrement la fnsea et
les ja la semaine dernière à l'issue de
la manifestation je vous explique très
rapidement cette loi a été créée après
ce qu'on a appelé les états généraux de
l'alimentation 15 mois de discussions et
ses conclusions ont été prises en
fonction de quels la quasi unanimité de
ce qui était dit d'un jugé à cet écho
dans les états généraux de
l'alimentation
c'était quoi il faut une meilleure
répartition de la valeur dans ce qu'on
appelle les négociations commerciales
qui commence du 1er décembre au 28 mars
ça marche pas forcément parce que c'est
des premiers à savoir est ce qu il faut
c est ce qu il ya des choses à améliorer
déjà ça ne marche pas parce que ça
démarre la wii mais ce qui est des
choses à améliorer ça ne marche pas
parce que la démarche est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui durer parce que j'ai une
relation payer la marque
il ya une commission de suivi du sénat
qui a déjà dit que ça ne fonctionnait
pas le nom mais que le compte n'y était
pas que les actions trouvait c'est moi
qui ai dit que quand tu y étais pas
simplement cette loi a été promulguée il
y a un an
les ordonnances ont été prises au
printemps et ça ne pouvait pas marcher
de ces années zéro utile là où nous
allons nous apercevoir ce qu'il en est
ou pas dans cette loi l'objectif c'était
que la répartition de la valeur se fasse
le mieux possible ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas acceptable aujourd'hui qu'un
agriculteur vendre un produit moins cher
que ce que ça lui salué la loi est bonne
il faut pas changer la halle pour
l'instant la loi est une loi équilibré
qui permettra espérons le dans les
négociations commerciales savez ça dure
trois mois par an des négociations
commerciales
c'est du 1er décembre au 28 février et
c'est là où 450 mille agriculteurs
passent devant dix sept mille
entreprises agroalimentaires mais
surtout de quatre centrales d'achat ils
sont 6 4 centrales d'achat qui règne en
maître sur le sujet des conséquences sur
l'ensemble ça c'est un vrai et ça c'est
un vrai problème sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne lorsque l'on voit par exemple il
n'ya que la grande distribution selon
ufc que choisir a eu un chèque en blanc
de 1,6 milliard d'euros et de l'autre
côté vous avez des pme qui continua qui
trinque à cause de cette loi agriculture
et alimentation le foie gras le
champagne par exemple qui se porte mal
parce qu'il ne peut plus ne peuvent plus
faire de promotion c'était des
instruments essentiels pour eux mais
quand même des vrais problèmes que ça va
franchement le champagne il faudra se
porte pas mal du tout excuser moi
regardez vos fichiers aujourd'hui c'est
pas les filières qui se portent le plus
bas la femme la seule chose qui la
conseilla par non la seule chose qui est
de sa m'étonnerai des entreprises de
foie gras ou de champagne avec la clé
sous la porte mais ça ce serait vous et
table et je ferai tout pour que ce ne
soit pas le cas
qu'est-ce qu'il a été décidé dans les
états généraux de l'alimentation
notamment par la profession agricole
c'est que l'on arrête les promotions
dans les grandes surfaces qui disent un
produit est vendu un produit acheté un
produit offert un produit gratuit
ce n'est pas possible ou alors ça veut
dire quelqu'un se rince sur le dos des
agriculteurs
donc nous avons pris des ordonnances
pour limiter des promotions en volume et
en valeur et notamment on peut faire de
plus un mais pas pour un c'est un peu
technique voilà ce qu'il a et ce qui a
été décidé c'est que pour les fêtes de
fin d'année il n'y avait plus de
promotions à moins 50 moins 60 - 70 %
vous a laissée
c'est une demande c'est une demande de
la profession et des rivières va voir ce
qu'il en est d'accord brigitte sur la
grille bachir parlé du malaise entre les
les français les agriculteurs finalement
comment vous allez faire pour redorer
l'image des éleveurs des agriculteurs
mais moi je crois que aujourd'hui c'est
en expliquant c'est en communiquant
positivement de leur part de la part des
professionnels de la part des
producteurs
aujourd'hui l'agriculture c'est pas un
handicap pour les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est pas un handicap
pour le réchauffement climatique c'est
peut être une des solutions savez des
forêts c'est un capteur de capteurs de
carbone extraordinaire les prairies
permanentes l'élevage quand ils
scandaient des vaches dehors dehors avec
sur herbe
c'est un captage du carbone également
donc il faut positiver ce l'annoncé des
campagnes de promotion ah oui mais vous
savez en ce moment dans le dans les
journaux et des campagnes de promotion
qui sont faits par l'interprofession de
la viande qui indique l' internet qu'ils
disent a bien marché en moi peut-être
mais banque géant mieux et regarder les
signes de qualité c'est parce que c'est
de la com y'a pas non c'est pas de la
com c'est de l'information je pense que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensent
qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'ils vont prendre
un produit
ils mangent mal c'est pour ça que je
danse une grosse opération sur
l'étiquetage parce que je pense que le
citoyen le consommateur lorsqu'il pousse
son caddie dans la grande surface
il doit le savoir ce qu'ils achètent
pour l'origine ce sera quoi l'étiquette
les on est en train de la mettre en
place je veux qu'ils sachent ce sera le
leur a bien sûr d'accord d'accord
l'origine l'origine de la matière
première
lorsqu'il est un plat cuisiné lorsqu'il
prêt lâche est un poulet lorsqu'ils
achètent
il faut savoir d'où ça vient mais déjà
dans le passé mais je sais pas mais pas
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas et moi
ce que je veux c'est du patriotisme du
patriotisme agricole du patriotisme
économique c'est à dire que lorsque je
vais acheter
mais je préfère acheter français qu'elle
allait transformer pour notre
agriculture maintenant de glyphosate
avait oui effectivement
emmanuel macron a semblé dire que le 1er
janvier 2021 pour date pour arrêter le
glyphosate ça pouvait être compliqué
peut-être pas faisable
est ce que vous vous tenez à cette date
du 1er janvier janvier 2021 et où vous y
at il un nouveau calendrier
et puis avec des changements selon les
cultures peut-être si non mais c'est pas
le problème du glyphosate en tant que
tel c'est le problème de tous les
produits phytopharmaceutiques
moi ce que je souhaite comme min
c'est que nous arrivions à quitter la
dépendance à tous les produits sur le
calendrier mais je vais vous rendez vous
savez faut faire attention à ce combat
d'un voilage comme ça parce que c'est
entendu par les citoyens aussi si je
peux me permettre
donc la quitter tous les produits
phytopharmaceutiques le plus vite
possible notamment - 50% en 2025
voilà ce que c'est notre objectif parce
qu'il ya pas que le glyphosate car la
drire et son riff deuxièmement parce que
je jure 2020 je réponds à cette question
sur 2021 le président de la république a
été très clair
et moi j'ai justement dans cette ligne
on quitte la dépendance au glyphosate en
fin 2021 pour toutes les filières ou une
alternative
là où il n'y a pas d'alternative ça ne
sera pas combien à quel pourcentage je
peux pas vous dire j'espère que ça sera
ça mais je peux on peut pas le dire ont
dû cesser tout cela c'est pas c'est pas
mathématique je vais prendre un exemple
l'agriculture de conservation lhériteau
de conservation tout le monde en parle
c'est la nouvelle agriculture où on a
plus de labour où tout se fait
naturellement pour que ça fonctionne il
faut quand même utilisé un petit peu de
glyphosate sans glyphosate pas
d'agriculture de conservation est ce
qu'on va à l'interdire si c'est très
petit pour ce il ya forcément certains
endroits par exemple dans la viticulture
dans le living qui sont en pente etc
il n'y a pas de possibilité peut-être
ben on verra bien par contre j'ai
développé un moment le chiffre 90% des
mois la même confirmé voilà je ne peux
pas confirmer le chiffre soit le plus
possible mais moi ce qui m'importe
surtout c'est que les agriculteurs ont
tous compris sont tous lancés dans cette
transition agro écologiques et cela
c'est vraiment terrible jour c'est
qu'ils seront présentés dans et ça
avance
ils seront prêts en 2000 par seront pris
en 2001 2002
l'inra notre institut national de
recherche agronomique travaille beaucoup
les instituts il faut des alternatives
aux produits chimiques à l'ordre il ya
un autre produit qui est pointé du doigt
je vais regarder ma fiche parce que je
ne connaissais pas il ya une heure non
plus c'est le chlorpyrifos méthyle
brigitte wii qui serait un insecticide
très toxique pour les foetus et les
jeunes enfants c'est le monde qui a
enquêté et qui nous dit c'est ce choix
est ce que vous vous engagez à interdire
le renouvellement de ceux de ce produit
alors il ya deux choses c'est très
technique
le chlorpyrifos la france a émis un avis
négatif nous sommes très opposées mais
je rappelle c'est pas la france qui
décide c'est l'union européenne et pour
le méthyle nous attendons encore de
savoir d'avoir quelques renseignements
supplémentaires pareil des instituts de
de l'efsa de toutes les organismes mais
ray simplement la france émettra un avis
très négatif savez notre rôle et mon
rôle c'est aussi de protéger la santé
des actifs ici au niveau autorisé qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est décidé d'autoriser
dette autorisé et la france sera obligée
nord sera pas obligé parce que ce ne
sera qu il faut sa trame le glyphosate
mais moi je suis opposé à que oui je
suis opposé à tous les produits qui
peuvent mettre en grand danger la santé
de nos concitoyens nous travaillons pour
le principe de précaution nous
travaillons pour la meilleure santé de
nos concitoyens donc sur le premier nous
sommes défavorables devant déjà dit à
l'union européenne
sur le deuxième il est vrai sa vague que
nous le serons mais si je veux être
objectif la décision n'est pas prise
puisque nous attendons les dernières
études très attendu pour lorsque dans
les jours qui viennent jeter à corps
save et rapide on est très très très
rapide ça sort l'union européenne va pas
si j'ai bien compris va pas prendre une
décision avant la fin de l'année je
crois et un autres insecticides kiev le
chlordécone que vous connaissez sûrement
ya un rapport parlementaire qui est
sorti pour lutter contre le charançon
c'est ça dans les bananes aux antilles
il ya un rapport parlementaire qui
pointe finalement un scandale d'état une
très forte responsabilité de l'état
comment vous allez réparer ce qui aura
une commission de suivi est ce que vous
savez à combien le chlordécone utilisé
il put puis depuis une trentaine
d'années notamment aux antilles par des
entreprises clientes et faites par des
entreprises françaises
le président de la république emmanuel
macron été le premier président de la
république à reconnaître la
responsabilité de la france d'avoir
continué cette utilisation
aujourd'hui les choses sont ce qu'elles
sont il ya une commission denquête j'ai
été auditionnée comme madame busin comme
madame vidal comme madame
jardin eh bien nous allons tirer les
conclusions la commission denquête qui
viennent de nous être rendus et
libération qui sont envisageables
réparations financières soient entendus
c'est ce que c'est ce que demande la
c'est ce que demande la commission
denquête il faut regarder l'ensemble de
la de la sinisation exclu ce n'est pas
exclu mais c'est compliqué de répondre
de répondre à cela puisque la commission
d'enquêté un rapport parlementaire qui
vient de nous être rendus il faut que le
gouvernement réagisse et puis disent
qu'il va faire table oui des dépôts de
carburants sont bloqués et font craindre
une pénurie dans les stations service
pour protester contre la suppression du
gnr ça concerne aussi les tracteurs les
engins gréasque gazole non le gazole le
gazole non routier lui les nazis
davantage
voilà est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut
y avoir une contagion pour les
agriculteurs non mais aujourd'hui dans
une situation nationale où c'est tendu
c'est tendu parce qu'il ya des
revendications sociales vers des
revendications catégorielles et des
revendications sectorielles le gazole
non routier
l'agriculture n'est pas concerné
puisqu'il est totalement détaxés ya pas
sauf pour les entreprises sur le gazole
non routier
après les arrivées en cause de travaux
paye le gazole non routier gazole non
routier est taxé et je peux pas moi je
veux pas regarder de cristal ce qui va
se passer
j'espère simplement que dans la
concertation qui est menée par le
gouvernement par le le ministre les
ministres concernés notamment du
ministre de transition écologique et
solidaire on arrivera à trouver une
solution de l'accession pour parfois on
est parfois en
on critique on regrette on est vrai et
ce pouvoir et les jupes les terriens
tout et discutent décidé à l'elysée il
n'y a pas de discussion nous écoute pas
et puis quand on est en concertation
négociations sur les retraites sur tous
les sujets on dit mais qu'est ce que
vous fichez une dernière c'est la france
c'est pour ça qu'on les aime
une dernière question de brigitte vous
allez vers 16h à la consommation au mois
de janvier les associations regrettent
que le gouvernement finalement ne
communique pas sur ce drame january est
ce que il faut y voir le poids des
lobbys je sais pas ce qu'est un lobby
c'est maintenant je sais pas si si les
viticulteurs de france on les traite de
lobby je trouve ça absolument scandaleux
ce sont des aviculteurs le drive chanut
arides comme vous dites dans un mois 150
pas toi de moi sans alcool moi je suis
très opposé à titre personnel tout ça
c'est de la com à l'automne prochain
tout ça c'est de la com ça ne veut
absolument rien dire moi je prône la
modération toute l'année plutôt que la
prohibition pendant un mois
je suis opposé à la prohibition donc moi
je suis opposé au mois de janvier sans
alcool par contre je me suis
suffisamment exprimé souvent pour dire
que ben voilà c'est mieux la modération
c'est multi lutter contre les addictions
c'est mieux de faire en sorte que les
jeunes boivent moins fasse pas de benchs
drinking pour un autre mot patois
français etc
c'est tout cela merci brigitte merci tap
est évidemment à lundi prochain une
question par filière volaille
pourquoi ne pas réserver dans nos
grandes surfaces des rayons une zone qui
serait géré directement par les
agriculteurs ou les prix seraient enfin
équitable alors dans nos grandes
surfaces gens ça me semble la question 2
ap la pression c'est une question
essentielle parce que ce que je constate
de plus en plus c'est qu'il y a dans nos
dans nos villes des magasins de
producteurs
les chambres d'agriculture fond des
choses remarquables je vais faire une
publicité
je suis allé inaugurer anime la maison
des agriculteurs c'est piloté par la
chambre d'agriculture par des
associations
c'est un magasin une grande surface
uniquement de produits agricoles de
légumes de fruits il faudrait besoins
des grandes surfaces et et ça marche
très très bien pourquoi pas dans la base
je sais pas juridiquement comment les
choses peuvent se faire mais bien peu
turier il ya de plus en plus avec moi je
souhaite je souhaite tout ce qui pourra
permettre de faire de la vente directe
pour les agriculteurs pour les
dans nos villes mais il n'ya pas que la
vente directe qu'il faut aussi qu'ils
aient des débats sur la question mais
j'avais dans les grandes surfaces y ait
beaucoup d'efforts qui est fait pour le
l'agriculteur du coin pour pour l'une
d'elles s'avance tout cela je crois on
va cueillir maintenant les
parlementaires qui veulent débattre avec
vous de plusieurs questions
[Musique]
nos parlementaires qui arrive sur ce
plateau martial bourquin sénateur ps du
doubs bonsoir bonsoir richard ramos
député modem du loiret bonsoir bonsoir
on était sur les retraites on va y
rester avec martial bourquin pour
commencer sur les retraites le
remboursement de cette de la dette
sociale
c'est là dessus que vous voulez aller et
le fait qu'il n'y a pas forcément
urgence dites vous je pense que je pense
vraiment qu'il ya un matraquage pour
dire il est urgent de faire ce projet de
retrait j'essaie de me renseigner sur
cette question d'abord faut le dire
qu'en 2060 10 la france consacrera 3 3%
du pib en moins sur les retraites qu'en
2016 à dire le pic en 2025
c'est là qu'elle pique la deuxième chose
c'est que lionel jospin a mis en place
un fonds de réserve des retraites en
il est de 32 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui 32 milliards qui sont là
justement pour le système de retraites
les régimes complémentaires qui sont des
réserves 116 milliards de réserves pour
les régimes complémentaires
on vient de parler de 150 milliards
attention ici disponible mais attendez
on va on va beaucoup plus loin parce que
la sécurité sociale et à l' équilibre
bientôt elle aurait été cette année s'il
n'avait pas eu des dépenses indues qui
lui avait été imposé et qui sont
contraires à la loi veil
la cades est ce la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale la
sécurité sociale qui sera complètement à
l' équilibre à partir de 2024 24
milliards d'euros seront disponibles ou
votre question et bien écoutez pourquoi
il ya tant de précipitation
je pense que ce
système à points existe déjà en suède
quatre années de suite où le
gouvernement vient de décider la baisse
du point et la baisse des retraites donc
ça c'est fait nous il ya très peu de
temps avec la part par la csg je pense
que c'est un système inique
donc qu'est-ce que ça c'est pourquoi
cette précipitation pourquoi cette
précipitation et surtout on laisse
surtout j'ai revenir mais d'abord à la
question mais il n'y a aucune
précipitation aucune puisque ça bien été
annoncée par le premier ministre il n'y
aura pas de transition brutale dans ce
régime de retraite
le fonds de retraite près de 32
milliards chaque année deux régimes de
retraite en gros fait 17 milliards de
déficit en gros en deux ans le fonds de
retraite il est mort donc moi la
différence peut-être de martial bourquin
je ne veux pas que mes enfants vivent à
crédit
je veux qu'ils puissent avoir un régime
un régime de retraite qui soit qui soit
équilibrée donc moi je vais pas partir
dans ce qui va se passer en 2082 mills
pas quoi où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui
prise de la république avait annoncé
dans sa campagne avant que soit
président et annoncer qu'on ferait ce
système ce système il va être plus juste
il va être plus équitable
moi je vois que machete burqa et
d'autres vont très simplement un fst
jeudi aux côtés de tout nom du front
national et ses portes mais en tout cas
contre cette manifestation mais s'est
manifesté fin quand cette réforme et
s'est manifesté contre le fait par
exemple ou en prenant tout l'instant que
les agriculteurs aient une retraite qui
sera l'adjoint de ce nom alors qu'ils
n'ont pas si ça locle a maintenant je
termine alors qu'ils ne l'ont pas qu'ils
ne l'ont pas aujourd'hui ça veut dire
que demain les femmes qui ont des
carrières hachées qui aujourd'hui et moi
j'ai soutenu le quinquennat précédent et
géo kg aucun point nature enfin on n'a
pas réglé cette question nous allons
régler aujourd'hui les femmes touchent
42% de moins de revenus que oui mais
c'est aujourd'hui que démarre écriture
sur le point je vous dis moi pourquoi je
vous dis pourquoi il faut le faire on ne
fait pas précipitamment c'est pas demain
mais je vous dis simplement que c'est
pour régler ce genre qu'il était
essentiel donc sur le point sur le point
les négociations ne sont pas terminées
encore avec les organisations syndicales
et nous pensons que ça pourrait être une
revoyure tous les cinq ans et que si ça
doit être les syndicats qui ont leur mot
à dire là dedans j'ai pas de sujet mais
pour apprendre le système qui se passe
chez paou
en suède un système français ça donne
simplement ce que je ce que je voudrais
dire en quelques mots si le point et de
l'autorité de l'état
inévitablement l'état quel qu'il soit
aura tendance à taper dans les retraites
comme ça c'est fait il y a un an et demi
rades rendez vous compte ce qui s'est
passé avec l'augmentation de la csg
est-ce que sur laquelle nous sommes
revenus et une en partie pas
complètement mais il se dit donc
beaucoup de retraités dont beaucoup
d'argent peuvent contribuer là c'est
donc ce que ça peut faire ce que l'on a
cru faire c'est prendre le temps parce
que avoir un régime universel d'accord
mais que le régime là aujourd'hui pour
les femmes qui ont vraiment des
inégalités épouvantable pour les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui avec la kadey
ce qui va s'arrêter en 2024
il y aurait des marges de manoeuvre pour
le faire on a calculé pour les
enseignants le snes vient de sortir une
étude mais ne sera pas le snes vient de
sortir une étude en disant simplement
une projection avec ceux qui arriveront
en 2025
les professeurs ils pourraient perdre
avec le système au point parce qu'il
n'ya pas les primes dedans alors jusqu'à
900 euros non mais là dessus c'est très
important et très déterminés c'est sûr
c'est très important ce que dit martial
bourquin parce qu'il dit le snes dit que
des enseignants 1800 euros
oui c'est vrai avec un économiste un oui
mais avec un économie c'est vrai que le
snes dit que les océans pendant 800
euros et bien moi je dis que c'est un
mensonge parce que non parce que
pourquoi pour mais je vais vous répondre
très tranquille et après on passe parce
que pour l'instant le gouvernement n'a
pas encore annoncé ce qu'il faudrait
pour les enseignants
qu'est ce qui se passe pour les
enseignants aujourd'hui des enseignants
sont pas très bien payé
donc ils ont plus de congés que d'autres
mais ils ont leur retraite sur les six
derniers mois évidemment si nous
appliquions éléments sont pas comptées
les plus mal payés
on y rendit à tous on est à tous
contribué mais donc évidemment si le
système rentrée comme cela les
enseignants perdre et c'est pas ça une
chose c'est pas ça qui va se passer je
veux dire pas la volonté du gouvernement
que les avez dit que vous allez dire
entièrement une clause de revoyure tous
les cinq ans oui oui pour le point vert
entre qui et qui
entre les organisations syndicales et le
gouvernement a dénoncé l'arbitrage en
dérapage en jeu on peut pas reprocher
que tout en haut puis quand on discute
avec des syndicats non mais je vois
comment ça allait super bien on a misé
de l'agriculture en face de nous on va
parler maintenant d'agriculture
d'écologie et c est richard ramos à des
questions précises à vous poser entre
particuliers le camembert au lait cru
oui c'est précis alors d'abord tout
simplement parce que moi comme le
ministe d'ailleurs qu' à titre personnel
répond au député je crois que c'est l'un
des meilleurs sur le sujet donc ça c'est
une grande force l'agriculture ce n'est
pas qu'un produit
l'agriculture c'est quand pouces quelque
chose c'est une civilisation et on a des
produits phares comme ça et donc le
camembert au lait cru je suis pas député
normand et est quelque chose qui parle
aux français
et aujourd'hui on est en débat et et je
disais est ce que le ministre de
l'agriculture sera le fossoyeur du goût
français dire c'est ça ma question je
les aime bien mais je voudrais pas qu'on
le vire et bien c est ce que le ministre
va faire en sorte qu'on ait le droit de
mettre du lait pasteurisé dans la op
camembert de normandie
c'est à dire que derrière on nous
racontera plein de choses plein filière
d'agriculteurs quand on mange un
camembert avec une appellation qui est
public qu'elle aop on mange l'excellence
française sont autorisées sans lait
pasteurisé ou parce que si on met du
lait pasteurisé
on n'a plus le goût du terroir le lait
cru c'est un morceau de francs vont
alors le se répondent les dos est-ce que
ce ministre que j'apprécie va devenir le
fossoyeur du goût français sur le
camembert est ce que vous allez prendre
un décret pour interdire des pastorales
bancaire en principe ce qu'on me
reproche c'est pas d'être le fossoyeur
de la viticulture ou de l'alimentation
c'est plutôt l'inversé
après tout n'est pas clair sur ce sujet
très important à noah j'ai un souvenir
ému d'un mardi après-midi aux questions
d'actualité au gouvernement où monsieur
ramos avait offert 577 camembert bien
fait à tous les députés et l'assemblée
nationale tout le monde se rappelle
encore mais je vais vous répondre
pourquoi parce que il défend il défend
ce sujet je sais ce que vous allez
prendre un décret par exemple pour
interdire et aujourd'hui nous savons qui
est lui un vrai débat au niveau au
niveau normand sur le sur le camembert
l'appellation camembert de normandie il
se trouve et pour revenir très très très
sérieux david qui a eu des enfants qui
ont eu des difficultés de santé par
rapport au lait cru
voilà et nous nous sommes obligés de
tenir compte du principe de précaution
parce que moi je suis pour tous mais à
un moment quand même lorsqu'il ya un
enfant qui décède ou un enfant qui est
malade les parents et 10 passes étaient
bien on défend le goût français on est
là donc tout simplement c'est que
aujourd'hui lens s l'autorité
indépendante de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments demande à ce qu'on ne fasse pas
consommer de lait cru aux enfants de
moins de 6 ans que ça veut dire quoi
mais ça veut dire que pour les enfants
demain pour l'art et je sais pas à qui
cela mais je préfère le dire je sais
c'est pas la question mais je préfère
qu'ils aimaient le rugby mais vous
botter en touche en pas du tout je
prépare le grand ménage entre ces deux
là excusez moi excusez moi c'est pas la
question
le lait cru on ne demande pas
l'interdiction du lait cru on dit
simplement que dans la réponse n'a rien
à voir avec la question mais cela ma
question c'est sur la au pk lambert de
normandie est ce que vous allez faire en
sorte vous ministre de l'agriculture
qu'on puisse mettre du lait pasteurisé
dans une appellation qui aujourd'hui les
voilà ça c'est la question précise oui
mais moi je réponds sur l'ensemble s'est
désolé j'ai une réserve en chasser les
pots et c'est donc je finis sur le lait
cru pour les enfants de moins de deux
moins de cinq ans parce que les normes
débat comme les années dans le débat
mais d'accord sinon j'étais moi-même cet
après midi aux assises du lait cru bon
avec avec les scientifiques allaient
avec avec nick nolte on les sent proche
et très bien qu'aujourd'hui à unadilla
une division sur ce sur ce sujet
déterminant mais alors là oui c'est à
nous et à notre débat mais ça nous la
tenons mais je parle je parle du
camembert à je reviens sur le camembert
qu'à une énorme division sur le sur le
sujet et que pour l'instant nous sommes
en train de discuter sur tous ces sujets
les ailières plusieurs pour l'instant
c'est que le
camembert façon vous la laissez pas tout
blanc ou tout noir les choses à votre
avis en discuter en discute mais moi je
n'ai pas d'avis autre que la vie de mon
ministère et pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore tranchée n'en vient pas bien et
je sais il le sait très bien
c'était même analyse d'ailleurs en
sachant quand même qu'on pourrait dire
la même chose pour le comté pour le
monde vient alors alors vous allez
parler par contre du boeuf non non vous
allez parler de l'accord d'importation
de boeuf américain qui a été signé ces
derniers jours dans l'union européenne
parce que ça c'est un sujet qui vous
intéresse aussi qui intéresse au miso et
les cultures
moi je pense tous ces accords
internationaux ont vécu que soit l'état
que là on est en train de remettre en
place le taffetas quand vous allez
acheter un steak qui vaut mieux
l'acheter vers nos agriculteurs qui ont
beaucoup de difficultés à les vendre
souvent plutôt que de l'acheter qu'ils
fassent un qu'il est un bilan carbone
catastrophique
voyez pas sur le lait cru les fromages
au lait cru
on abordait tout à l'heure je l'écoutais
la question des pesticides du glyphosate
on va faire du zèle sur le lait cru et à
côté de cela on aura bornera pas les
vraies questions concernant
l'agriculture
moi je le dis à didier guillaume on a le
sénat a voté contre le budget
agriculture avec une chose essentielle
en ce qui nous concerne on a besoin
d'une révolution dans l'agriculture
les français aiment les agriculteurs
évolution et celle de la grogne l'agro
agriculture celle de du bio parce que
les français
moi je vais dans un magasin je fais les
courses souvent et quand je vois bio
espagne bio belgique
ça me fait mal au coeur donc les j'ai
envie que ce soit vrai et que ce soit
fabriqué que se soit produit dans nos
agriculteurs bien de chaleur et le
passage au bio n'est pas assez le
passage au bio et en plus ensuite une
fois qu'on est au bio le fait que c'est
une pérennité de ces de ces subventions
on aurait dû augmenter considérablement
aujourd'hui cela me ferait
c'est dans le projet de loi de finances
de l'année dernière il ya un plan
ambition bio qui était doté de 1
milliard cent millions n'a jamais été
fait dans les 20 ans qui viennent de s'y
garer
ça n'a jamais été fait aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 10 % des agriculteurs en bio
dans la culture française
nous sommes à 7 5% la surface agricole
utile l'objectif de la loi devant fixer
s'abaisser pas assez d'accord enfin
l'objectif de cloud à en fixer ces 15%
donc les conversions en bio de ce fonds
mais je veux revenir sur les sur les
accords internationaux
je partage l'avis de martial bourquin
les accords internationaux ils ont vécu
ils ont vécu parce que les décisions
qu'ils ont prises par l'union européenne
et je suis très à l'aise je suis pro
européen jean prises par l'union
européenne d'imposer aux états
c'est assez compliqué c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'on n'en verra pas d'autres
c'est pour ça que le mercosur a été mis
de côté qui ne sera jamais remis à
l'ordre du jour mais il existe des
accords internationaux que le
gouvernement précédent a préparé suis
d'abord sud avant et celui ci aux yeux
et notamment par rapport aux états qui
n'est pas encore ratifié par la france
non mais il est maître il ya 90 % et à
100% puisque c'est ça c'est ça
l'histoire c'est que le lavaux trappe le
vacon oui vraisemblablement le ceta le
ceta est appliquée depuis deux ans mais
il n'a pas encore été ratifiée par la
france c'est ça le la subsidiarité
européenne bon donc quel est le sujet
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on a
besoin de faire cadre du commerce avec
les les pays qui sont des pays qui ont
quasiment les mêmes standards que les
nôtres aujourd'hui si nous voulons
exporter des produits français mais vous
ne voulons pas en importer ça n'a aucun
sens on est dans une économie ouverte et
je pense moi que par rapport aux c'est à
l'accord avec le canada il n'y a aucun
risque sur la sur l'agriculture pas en
importations de boeuf c'est 60 60 tonnes
pour l'instant de boeuf importés nous
venons d'en exporter 300 tonnes en chine
bon j'ai manqué la semaine de produits
phytosanitaires ne sont pas autorisés
chez nous n'ont pas terminé
non parce que des laboratoires qui skie
sur et non ça c'est pas vrai par contre
il ya un sujet et un sujet sur lequel
nous travaillons avec le canada c'est
par rapport aux farines animales
ça c'est un vrai art in fine c'est un
vrai sujet pas de farines animales de
ninon n'y a pas de sujet ça c'est
interdit en france mais ce que nous
disons nous c'est que tout ce qui est
importé en europe et en france doit
être importées au niveau du standard et
de l'avoir cette garantie à 6 pour le
ceta nous l'avons il ya des contrôles
qui sont faits et nous il ya des choses
qui chara motion e au ministre est face
à nous sur l'agroécologie je dire s'il
ya un ministre qui se bat pour
l'agroécologie c'est lui et donc je
trouve que parce qu'ils nous bassinent
tout le temps avec sa semaine donc oui
oui mais quand j'ai quelque chose à dire
je le dis sans aucun problème et c'est
un ministre qui se base sur
l'agroécologie sur la transformation de
la montée en gamme passe au dessus messi
va s'éveiller il le fait parfaitement
juste ghsr contre je pense que oui ce
que vous avez dit sur la ratification
européenne des accords avec les
américains sur la viande de boeuf est
une connerie c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
pas les mêmes standards que nous et
l'europe via leurs actifs richard ramos
des jeux tels que par rapport aux états
unis la france il trouve c'était moi qui
étais à bois à bruxelles toujours là a
voté contre à voter contre la
ratification la poursuite de la coque
des états unis la france est opposée
mais c'est englobé dans le dans le
ravisseur ramos vous travaillez vous est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs là les sanctions
sur lovano viticulteurs je veux quand
même le dire pour le faire nos
viticulteurs qui jaunissent non parce
que je les ingrédients nous nous
planchons sur l'un des comptes sur le
volant des contrats liés que au moment
où on se fait taxer nos produits
agricoles où on remet en place le
taffetas d'une certaine façon c'est pas
aimé c'est une volonté de l'euro les
actionnaires sont amis mais sinon non
mais si tu ne peux pas dire sociale la
france est opposée
oui j'ai eu la france a voté contre
alors après on peut dire c'est l'europe
qui ne fonctionne pas alors la france
est opposée mi mai c'est clair net après
il faudra des clauses de sauvegarde pour
ne pas les appliquer le président de la
république a dit qu'il fera des clauses
de sauvegarde et voilà vous avez loin du
bandeau de sauvegarde c'est clair des
clauses séguin c'est clair richard ramos
vous défendez demain un amendement
contre le sel ni traité ou précisément
vous allez préciser ça ait posé la
question au ministre j'avais déjà
défendu dans le cadre du budget de la
sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui l'organisation mondiale de
santé nous dit il ya des risques avérés
axel kahn aujourd'hui sur la ligue
contre le cancer
une pétition aujourd'hui qui est déjà à
deux cent mille exemplaires 10 on a un
risque de pour la santé publique
du sel nitrites et dans la charcuterie
notamment dans les jambes alors je
connais xittel un procédé qui permet de
rosir les lardons alors il a mis deux
trois choses alors les rillettes elle a
quasiment pas c'est sûr jambon blanc
pour fait du bien ça permet deux choses
1 c'est qu'à voir la couleur rose et 2
c'est à dire c'est ça permet avec un
kilo de viande d'en fabriquer quasiment
2 0 a ajouté du sel nitrites et un petit
peu de poudre de perlimpinpin phosphates
et vous mettez de l'eau et vous et
richard virenque c'est un petit joueur
le taux de prévalence avoir peu de doute
mais voilà votre amendement dont on aura
demain je défends l'idée que quand il ya
du sel du traité dans un produit
alimentaire puisque on a aussi le
ministre de l'alimentation comme il ya
un risque avéré on puisse tout
simplement dire il ya du sel nitrites et
de danse une étiquette sur l'étiquette
et pourquoi parce que encore une fois
c'est la guerre et je dis bien c'est la
guerre entre le fric et le goût c'est à
dire que pourquoi on met du sel nitrites
et parce que dans un bon pays où on fait
du jambon de bayonne
c'est con sèche un jambon en trois mois
le de sécher en neuf mois et et bayonne
dans son appellation aujourd'hui va
retirer le saloum richard à bossou
demandé au ministre de la culture c'est
un peu de tout oui à cet amendement
l'amendement je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit soutenu mais par contre je ne
voudrais pas d'abandon est un élément
soutien nous on nous parle nous parlons
de rationalité nous parlons de la
science voilà le maintien des bsaar b b
g vous ne soutenez pas les attendez
attendez mais alors un incroyable lavage
nouri mais vous pose experts montceau et
artistes vous avez raison mais en pévèle
on peut pas répondre comme cela
aujourd'hui simple interview pas la
ministre de la santé
la ministre de la santé dit que
l'autorité européenne l'efsa de la santé
dit qu'il n'y a pas de risque
enfin en dessous d'un certain d'un
certain 50 50 g de charcuteries par jour
on a dix huit fois plus de chance donnée
d'avoir un cancer colorectal mais c est
madame nathalie la santé se tromper dans
abidjan
c'est trop pour la santé non aux
ministres de deux façons de façon un
soutien dredge allen montré la teneur
la teneur maximale en nitrites à 120 mg
par kilo quand 150 aujourd'hui c'est ça
l'orientation de laquelle qu'on va une
baisse après moi je ne connais pas cet
amendement qui va être présenté d'ici
l'été pour dire c'est que moi je suis
favorable je suis favorable du tri score
je suis favorable l'étiquetage je peux
pas je peux pas vraiment me bernard
ghana dans l'armée mais attention à la
marianne j'ai zappé pas tort je suis
avec serge est ouverte sur le sujet ça
n'a rien à voir avec le serbe irrité que
je suis favorable à tout ce qui va
permettre c'est pas la peine de
s'exciter être ce qui va permettre
d'informer non mais à tout ce qui va
permettre d'informer le construire
le client pourquoi parce que je ne sais
pas de quoi il s'agit là qu'est le
remettant sur les soutiens du sel
nitrites et juste mais je ne peux pas
vous répondre maintenant nous allons
regarder ce que nous ferons de mal je ne
sais pas qui va répondre pour l'instant
le gouvernement ne soutient pas
spécialement cet amendement sera
spécialement bien c'est dommage parce
que la question ne lui en quelque sorte
on vit une période où il ya besoin d'une
montée en gamme de notre agriculture de
notre industrie agroalimentaire et je
défends des les amendements ce matin en
séance sur ces questions nous avons des
pme des tpe
on a des deux pays qui fonctionne qui
ont fonctionné qu'un certain modèle et
qui ont besoin de changer profondément
il faut que le gouvernement les haines
ce matin on était sur les pôles de
compétitivité ont visité avec alain
chatillon le pôle de compétitivité de
toulouges de l'agroalimentaire il nous
disait si vous voulez qu'on emmène nos
pme tpe à cette montée en gamme dans
l'alimentation pour que justement on
puisse avoir de vrais produits parce que
c'est par écouter sur ces questions là
il faut tenir tête à l'europe
est ce que vous savez que toutes les
régies d'eau en allemagne sont tout
public et que quand ils ont adhéré à
l'europe pour lui mais il contient des
raiders hop on dit on ne discute pas ça
chez nous bon alors est belle nous ayons
nous ce que la question je posais sait
que c'est sur la vie non non non mais
sur les produits vrais au lait cru sur
les nitrites il faut savoir à un moment
donné se faire respecter en europe en
disant ne sait des choses sur lesquelles
on ne naît gaullien pas est ce que la
france a du mal à se faire respecter la
france n'a aucun mal à se faire
respecter en europe je ne crois pas la
france le problème de l'europe sexy du
tout seul on s'entend très bien et
encore quatre ou cinq galeries la preuve
on voit ce soir mais on est 27 28 et
demain 27
et je rappelle à tous nos amis qu'il
faut être il faut des majorités
qualifiées donc nous battons tous les
jours
tous les jours nous faisons en france le
pacte productif pour justement permettre
aux pme de l'agroalimentaire qui sont
formidables de pouvoir dire mieux
embaucher richard d'avoir mieux exporté
voulais vous poser une question précise
sur le bien manger sur le bien manger je
veux simplement simplement dire
qu'aujourd'hui on aura un enjeu de
demain
c'est l'information aux consommateurs
des halles hier qu'aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on le sache ce soit pour ceux qui
nous écoutent les applications vont
dépasser les marques c'est à dire que
l'ensemble des achats qui va se faire en
france vont ne plus faire sur le choix
d'une marque mais d'une application et
jeudi aux ministres parce que je les
apprécie même s'ils ont peu de temps
dans toutes ces questions c'est simple
aujourd'hui on n'a eu qu'à il ya 10
millions de français qui l'ont
téléchargée demain c'est une application
qui est privé qui sera vendu à d'autres
nous avons un outil qui s'appelle 60
millions de consommateurs et c'est à 74
millions de consommateurs de mettre tous
les acteurs pour la table pour créer un
outil consommateurs public
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à ce qu'on
travaille dans ce sens à moi je suis
prêt à ce que l'on travaille pour que
les nos concitoyens et les meilleures
informations possibles y compris
lorsqu'ils vont publier pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas un mauvais mari qu mais
bien sûr les tous les jeux draguera tu
aujourd'hui on parle de utah mais yucca
yucca et déjà dépassé parfois dépassé il
ya plein d'autres applications qui qui
sont qui sont en place aujourd'hui donc
mais bien sûr donc aujourd'hui est ce
que c est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est le ministère de la
culture est ce que ces derniers à
l'association des voix là est ce que
c'est les chambres d'agriculture c'est
tout cela autour la place mais autour
des enjeux lance quand je lance
l'étiquetage pour tous les produits
quand je veux une meilleure information
moi je n'oublie pas je suis ministre de
l'alimentation et visqueux l'alimentent
non mais c'est l'enjeu de demain dans
les rangs sociaux c'est l'enjeu de
demain est on ne peut plus faire
n'importe quoi mais je veux dire à
nouveau ce soir parce que j'aurais pas
qu'on se quitte en disant nous ça va pas
te fit non mais ça va mal en france au
niveau de l'alimentation les entreprises
agroalimentaires tout nous avons en
france sont de toute première qualité et
font des promus des produits de grande
hilarité
je voulais revenir gosses martial
bourquin merci d'être venu sur le gâteau
d'audition publique et maintenant c'est
très rare qui va faire son entrée
soieries bonsoir francis auriac au menu
et bien justement
bonsoir monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez donné faim il est bientôt 20h
d'ailleurs et j'ai fait y est arrivé
avec un camembert et quelques
substantifique aliments à vous donner
je vous écouter la conversation était
assez conviviale avec vos pairs prs et
je me disais il ya un vous tutoyez
l'autre vous êtes assez proche de lui
modem vous êtes de la majorité
présidentielle l'idée de la majorité
présidentielle que vous vous êtes encore
au parti socialiste non vous avez
déchirer votre carte
je n'ai pas déchirés je n'ai pas
reprises en 2017 et vous êtes alarm non
avant je ne suis plus je ne suis
adhérent aucune organisation politique
j'ai arrêté d'être j'ai arrêté d'être
parti socialiste au monde la
présidentielle rien j'ai considéré que
le toit de la primaire ne correspondait
pas à ce que je voulais et je voulais
dépasser depuis un moment les parties et
c'est pour ça que je me suis retrouvée
totalement derrière la nature des
manuels macron pas quand j'ai soutenu
dès le premier tour aux cages voelckel
j'ai voté j'étais dans sa majorité et je
me retrouve là la mère des réformes
manque du gouvernement la mère des
réformes qui s'approche il ya une
manifestation il ya des manifestations
dans toute la france jeudi et le
rassemblement national va défiler à côté
de votre ancien parti le parti
socialiste vous faire mal c'est un an
moi ça fait drôle ça fait drôle de c'est
la première fois
je crois dans l'histoire que ces deux
organisations politiques des filles dans
une manifestation
je suis pas faire d'amalgamé je trouve
que c'est dommage ça se passe comme ça
je trouve que c'est dommage que le parti
socialiste défilent contre une réforme
dont on n'a pas encore la teneur est
globalement qui est une réforme qui est
très progressiste maintenant passons aux
grappes à la teneur vous ne savez pas
ben on me dit vous avez pas mais je suis
désolé de vous dire que vous êtes je
suis est de vous dire compliqué de vous
suivre avoir à force de faire du cynisme
et de vouloir jouer au rythme des
réseaux sociaux on perd les français et
moi je ne peux pas te perdre les
français j'ai le souvenir ce qui s'est
passé il ya un an sur les ronds points
j'ai souvenir que la france enraciné s'y
retrouver dans la rue parce qu'elle a
l'impression de ne pas être entendus or
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore en
discussion ce que nous voulons gelé 10
sur les retraites le premier ministre a
remis trois dans quelques condamner les
socialistes qui vont défiler non je ne
condamne pas les seuls et ce qu'ils vont
défiler ils ont le droit de faire ce
qu'ils veulent je regrette qu'ils le
fassent pas ça c'est plus c'est vraiment
problème pourquoi vous dites parce que
cette réforme c'est une réforme de
justice sociale c'est une réforme l'un
brûlé tisser que nous la comté mais ça
devrait traiter ça n'a pas l'air de
porter 70 % des français sont favorables
ou parler les gilets jaunes madame si
benji haye qui est la porte parole du
gouvernement disait que justement cette
réforme était la réponse au mouvement
des gilet jaune
en quoi c'est la réponse au mouvement
des jdc est une des réponses
une des réponses le président la
république a déjà répondu en quoi en
bêta je vais vous répondre l'a déjà
répondu en mettant la baisse des impôts
sur le sur le revenu en supprimant la
taxe d'habitation
vous me posez une question je vous
réponds et pourquoi des vacances je
réponds je vous dis simplement si je
vous réponds mais moi il fait des
réponses un peu longue et j'ai dû
expliquer vous dis simplement que cette
année avec la réponse la première
réponse au gilet jaune du président de
la république pour les français c'est
700 euros de pouvoir d'achat en plus
c'est moins 350 euros de baisse d'impôts
et c'est moins 316 c'est moi l'arrivée
je vais répondre c'est moins 350 euros
et là vous occuper le terrain non les
retraits excusez moi de dire jeudi pathé
renn c'est ça la réalité dakar qu'on
répond pas en sociaux n'en les retraites
c'est une des réponses parce que par
exemple pour les femmes qui étaient
beaucoup sur les ronds-points beaucoup
restent beaucoup mais qui touchent
quasiment à la moitié
de retraite que les hommes les mères de
famille ils vont en faire les frais
d'ailleurs révélé pas du tout je sais
pas ce que révèle le figaro parce que la
retraite n'est pas encore arbitré mais
les femmes qui aujourd'hui touchent et
quasiment la moitié que les hommes d'un
cran la même chose on sent quand même
qu'il ya quelques éléments de langage
qui ont été lancées par le président de
la république et vous dit davantage
d'égalité
ceux qui sont visés dans les discours
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif c'est les
régimes spéciaux
c'est donc ratp les agents des services
publics notamment
vous êtes un vrai que ça ce n'est là il
ya une injustice oui ce sont les
privilégiés non ce ne sont pas des
privilégiés ce n'est pas une réforme
stigmatisante
c'est pas une réponse pour montrer du
doigt des jeunes et des autres c'est pas
une réforme quand les enseignants quand
la ratp
je ne sais trop quoi mais aujourd'hui il
faut passer de 42 système de retraite à
un seul c'est régime universel c'est ça
l'objectif mais les régimes spéciaux
sont quand même particulièrement visés
par ce que il s'est senti ont jugé c'est
l'ensemble les enseignants c'est pas les
enseignants c'est pas un régime spécial
et à d'autres catégories ce ne sont pas
des régimes spéciaux
par contre il faut que un point cotiser
et la même valeur pour tout le monde et
ce qui va fixer et c'est ça la valeur du
point c'est la discussion qui est en
train d'être monnaie j'ai lu ça dans le
figaro qui avait des discussions entre
les syndicats et l'exécutif et le haut
commissaire
alors il ya une réforme des retraites
mais il ya aussi des municipales dans
quelques mois
et ça vous y intéressez de près thouet
alors comme tout responsable tout de go
je vous pose la question vous êtes
candidat
le dit la rumeur court dans paris vous
êtes candidat à biarritz donc c'est
dément les rumeurs paris je m'en fiche
totalement parce que je ne suis pas
parisien attendus à biarritz je suis je
suis je fêterai vinciane moi je suis
ministre de la culture on en a marre on
parle de ça depuis une heure et je
m'occupe à 100 % des agriculteurs
deuxièmement les élections municipales
sont un moment important de la vie
politique et le président de la
république le premier ministre lorsqu'on
est acteur politique on n'est pas un
commentateur nour acteurs politiques qui
vont s'engager très lent alors vous
allez vous il se trouve qu'à biarritz
aujourd'hui le constat qui est fait
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de liste de large
rassemblement qu'il a des difficultés
avec la municipalité sortante et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas modem d'avec la
l'ensemble de la municipalité vous serez
coller et qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
citoyens biarrots qui sont tenues
mutuellement interpellé il ya un appel
qui a été fait des gens de la république
en marge les gens de du sort des gens
qui souhaitent que je sois candidat le
président de la république
le premier ministre demandait de ne pas
annoncer sa candidature avant le début
du mois de janvier
donc j'ai donc ça sera aux voitures
qu'il n'en serait pas là vous dites il
ya quand même un maire sentant qu'ils
aient modem est sur la liste de mes
ressentons il ya un secrétaire d'état
mais non mais qui est monsieur
jean-baptiste lemoyne à excuser moi vous
allez perdre vos téléspectateurs parce
que on n'a pas notre ère ils sont
emmenés dans la politique politicienne
il n'y aura pas deux ministres face à
face enrgy l'article du monde pour jésus
j'ai lu l'article du monde ce week-end
qui m'a bien peiné parce que franchement
dans la semaine où on vient de faire un
hommage national pour 13 militaires tués
où il ya eu six morts avec les
inondations où il va y avoir une semaine
non mais on la connaît ses discours là
vous les connaissez vous dit quelque
chose
oui mais les municipales aujourd'hui
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui sont partis
pour les municipales à mon avis va
falloir qu'ils tiennent sur la durée là
vous allez vous heurter si jamais vous
êtes candidat vous allez vous heurter je
vais dire au baron local qui est
françois bayrou mais pour les modèles
moi je suis un homme de rassemblement
je suis un homme d'apaisement je suis un
homme de discussion donc pour l'instant
j'ai entendu un centre de gens qui est
qui souhaite vous êtes souhaité qu'ils
souhaitent que je me présente nous
verrons bien le ca vous insérez lambiel
moment si si d'aventuré vous êtes tête
de liste donc pour le combat ses
fonctions non mais c'est pas c'est
normal vous quitter le gouvernement en
ce moment la fin des on en est pas
encore là
ah bon nous ne sommes pas encore là donc
rendez vous début janvier
rendez-vous dans les mois qui viennent
pour continuer à travailler sur l'allumé
vous afficher l'heure il devait y avoir
deux ministres est développée notamment
messi joue à peine six mois ne
m'attendais mais moi je rentre même pas
là dedans ça ça n'a quand même pas si
vous avez vous avez une phrase tout à
l'heure avec mes consoeurs brigitte
boucher avec ma conscience brigitte
boucher le boucher vous lui avez dit la
réforme des retraites vous l'avez laissé
entendre comme ça de toute manière elle
sera pas complètement fini avant 5 6 ans
7 ans ça veut dire que c'est déjà acquis
le président de la république sera
candidat à sa réélection
et c'était la peinture il me dit fuladu
alors mais plaisanciers pas je n'ai pas
ici je plaisante
ah ben moi je souhaite on n'en est pas
là encore oui je souhaite évidemment que
le président de la république le moment
venu fasse valoir son bilan les disques
il part pour un deuxième quinquennat
mais ce n'est pas de sujets dont nous
parlions des retraites en disant que la
retraite ça ne peut pas être la
transition ne peut pas être brutal d'un
seul coup mais ça peut pas être pour
cinq ans derrière question d'après vous
ce sera encore un match contre marine le
pen
malheureusement c'est qui ce cas non je
ne crois pas que ce soit acquis mais si
je vous regarde les sondages qui regarde
alors vie des français boudent est plus
au parti socialiste la division
aujourd'hui c'est plus entre la droite
et la gauche c'est entre us que le
premier président de la république
appelle les progressistes et les
populistes
alors alors ça j'en suis pas les
progressistes les populismes et ça je
suis convaincu que la majorité
présidentielle
c'est un bloc progressiste qui
travaillent dans le en même temps on est
capable car un projet bon qu'on soit de
droite ou de gauche de se mettre
d'accord jusqu'à maintenant les partis
politiques l'empêchait moi je suis très
favorable
moi je travaille au gouvernement avec
des hommes comme bruno le maire comme
gérald darmanin comme sébastien lecornu
qui sont des amis avec lesquels je
m'entends bien sur lesquels nous
trouvons des choses des choses positives
à faire ensemble bien transformer la
société
c'est cela qui est important aujourd'hui
on n'est pas candidat a pas une
candidature comme ça on te transformer
les choses et donc peut-être jusqu'aux
municipales merci yves bercy à bure
audition publique c'est votre audition
publique guillot une heure ensemble il
s'est dit plein de choses n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
sur figaro live sur les comptes twitter
de lcp public sénat
bonne semaine merci et à lundi prochain
19 heures